Roger stone hello Roger has appeared is
that a pocket watch god no it's actually
just have it pinned inside the pocket so
it looks like one well yeah that's I got
to be honest Roger when I was like it
when I was growing up I didn't I've told
this before but like chain wallets were
really cool but I didn't have a chain
wallet not even know what it was so I
was as a young poseur
I did I did paperclip a chain just to
belt loops it wasn't humiliating his
father used to call it your turnip let
me see your turnip that's right Wow yeah
I don't my grandfather man I said that
so now that's just that do you actually
look at that or is that just a showpiece
well I actually look at it although
you're paying cellphones a little more
efficient yeah it's easier it's faster
it is so now are you are you panicked at
this point today is 390 seventh day that
the media has predicted that I will be
indicted and I have it because I'm here
but don't you think that the fact that
it's All Quiet on the Western Front and
nobody's really talking about Roger
stone is is bad news and that feel
they'll actually know because the parade
of my friends and associates who had
been dragged before the grand jury all
know nothing and have nothing and
they've seen the Fallen faces of the
prosecutors in this he didn't he didn't
get a package for massage he he didn't
fly to Florida I've hardly took to Paris
or to London this is it's an inquisition
but there is no evidence that I had any
advanced knowledge of the hacking the
alleged hacking of the Democratic
National Committee by the Russians or or
WikiLeaks or the Mickey Mouse Club or
anyone else you weren't in Istanbul
three weeks ago where you know I haven't
left the country now in two years I bet
if nobody asks Rogers opinion on this I
think that the prince is going to be
replaced in Saudi Arabia what do you
think looks like he's overplayed his
hand a little bit you know cutting
somebody up with a chainsaw that's
usually crosses a line they used a
chainsaw
well I'm speculating they definitely
cast him into into pieces and removed
him according to the media reports so do
you think I don't think he's going to
survive but I think they're gonna
replace him well he's a strong man and
he manoeuvred internally in their
politics and he's protected by his
father but this is
this is gonna be tough to overcome the
big one you know and the idea that
khashoggi the guy who was killed he may
be a journalist but he's also deeply
involved with Saudi intelligence and
deeply involved in their internal
politics of course it is his
I guess his grandfather Adnan Khashoggi
who sold Trump the Trump princess the I
don't know I don t show you I knew the
name that's hard now to pronounce his
name I didn't realize they were related
yes I read that yesterday oh so now
Trump is in this position where look
it's a hundred and fifty billion dollars
worth of we have a relationship with
them but is there a way that the the
pressure will just push him to finally
have to go look we have to do something
about this or we can't do business with
you well and even more importantly his
son-in-law Jared Kushner is evidently
waning wait I'm desperate for a koala
trap by the way just cut it somebody
else grab the cough drops good remember
[ __ ] low steady a different technique
off you get them no that wasn't [ __ ]
look no do not get the well yeah alright
that's good okay yeah that was a story
thank you very much you think so yeah
yes without the heroism but were you did
you did you consider Che Guevara a hero
Chan wear his shirt all the time without
the murdering of innocent kind of
peasants that's exactly right
what makes them a hero to me yeah you
theorists go ahead now so he's so
khashoggi is also well connect think the
problem here is very much like North
Korea the Trump has been very quietly
trying to put together a real Middle
Eastern peace deal that involves
everybody the Egyptians the Syrians the
Israelis and so on I don't know where
it's coming together or not they're
working very hard on it quietly it'd be
another diplomatic coup I mean just the
fact that we're talking to the North
Koreans it's funny to see all these
Democrats say North Korea what's taking
so long
you mother's had 75 years and you could
even get the guy to the table right
we're talking and it's always worthwhile
to talk for peace in my opinion yeah I
think
something that Trump should get a lot
more a lot more credit for North Korea
thing like they credit just not done yet
and it's like you're right nobody else
made headway for all these years he at
least met with the guy they have some
kind of relationship and then people
that man has not done in two months and
we're going back and forth clearly this
talks going on whether it bears fruit or
not we don't know but it's always better
to talk than not talk particularly
people who might lab one into the men's
room at the Capitol so Trump is working
very hard on a behind-the-scenes Middle
Eastern peace deal I don't know the
specifics of it but this current gets in
the way we didn't need the Saudis doing
this how much ability sorry so how much
ability does the u.s. have if push comes
to shove to like to have the King go
look you got to replace this guy well
they're very tough and very stubborn and
very rich the Saudis the Saudis and they
have and they have a very substantial
defense capability and they understand
Washington sometimes better than we
understand it they have played the
Washington game with lobbyists and
influence-peddling remember bend our
prints Bin's Salton banned our was often
referred to as bend our Bush during the
bush days he was that close to the
American first family what have you
become in the last two weeks a fan of
young Kanye West I was always a fan oh
you were oh yeah but I liked his music
you did yes
Oh on an intellectual level favorite
album who could say you celebrate his
entire I love them all I like the whole
catalog specific singular I mean on an
intellectual plane nice far above me
obviously but if he'd been brought in to
talk to Barack Obama and said the exact
same thing right now we'd be saying he's
a genius
you think so I mean he run around saying
[ __ ] this and [ __ ] that and and I
love its onra no ma'am you have to curse
it's part of the deal
yeah when when I was a little racial um
but he was like you know I mean he was
rambling like a madman no yeah so I love
Kanye when he amazes my Poehler well he
was sleep-deprived he's falsely
diagnosed he's talking how's the
fundamentals though he's not in Korea
right African Americans have been voting
Democratic essentially since 1960
and what have they gotten for it nothing
right nothing right so synthetics that
he preaches self-responsibility
self-help economic expansion for black
people I think he's right do you think
it's got to deliver he gets a little
goofy that a lot of the right-wing
people all of a sudden have been like
this Kanye West he's the greatest I've
always loved Kanye West
means a little transparent now well he's
no Jim Brown we put you that way it's I
looked I think that that Trump ran for
office and you made certain promises we
build the cities protect state legalized
marijuana move it off of the Schedule
one list it's got to deliver right
that's great but now deliver he delivers
I think he can change the dynamics
whether you like it or not
polls that that I've looked at where the
methodology is relatively solid show
that just under a third of black people
like Trump that's up from the single
digits for Mitt Romney and John McCain
and George W Bush so feeling like that
on black Twitter well but black Twitter
doesn't reflect the average middle-class
working black person probably there are
more jobs in for everybody including the
black community and black unemployment's
at the lowest point in American history
the lowest point since we begin keeping
those statistics why does he get no
credit for that Trump well yeah like
what like what even people don't like
him think they can't give him any credit
you know anything he's done well they
wouldn't give him yeah they won't give
him credit for anything but also you
know I mean he ran a very divisive
campaign you're with us or against us so
you know I think Trump contributes to
this idea that like you pick a side and
that's the side you're on
but the side that's against him won't
admit that they're doing the same thing
but the division today in the country is
not Republican Democrat it's insiders
and Outsiders you know he ran against
the two-party duopoly ran against an
entrenched establishment that's been
running things for thirty years how have
they done how they doing endless war
we're without our inherent national
interests being clear erosion of our
civil liberties believe me they have
your metadata count on it I'm sure
a stagnant economy immigration policies
that cheat the people who are waiting in
line to get in the country legally did
you find out that they have my metadata
when you had lunch with Julian Assange
he showed me your whole file a quick
file yeah very small but yeah I mean I I
do think that people get swept up in
that division right like people for
whatever reason are feeling like they
need to be on a side and some people
will admit that they're on a side and
some people think that they're not but
they are right the the opposition tends
to feel like well no I'm just open to
whatever well the media is dominated by
elites I would I believe that who are
essentially a part of the establishment
he doesn't help himself when he you know
calls stormy dating a horse-faced that I
don't think that was a you wouldn't know
you wouldn't have advised I think I
would let it ride frankly he won the
lawsuit right I just let it ride what
about when he said that he was looking
forward to the lawsuit in Texas because
the legal fees that she would have to
pay him are a plentiful yeah well
money's always been in the bottom line
you like so as far as her lawyer Michael
other night he goes the guy should have
red stones rules
what were those rules that would have
helped him yeah a good question Bob I'm
being a little facetious but he's out
there he's in your face and let's face
it six months ago none of us even heard
of him he's household word in terms of
the American body politic now much more
lawyer how many sqb poor lawyer how much
do you think Trump's legal fees are that
she's gonna have to pay for that case
you you operate in that world I have no
idea who represented him in the matter I
do know he hates paying lawyers and so I
guarantee you he did it on the cheap huh
you think Tim you think even for this
when he was like if I get an expensive
lawyer we might be able to win and get
the legal fees paid in Donald Trump's
mind the word expensive and lawyers
never go together
he doesn't like spending a lot on
lawyers he hates or accountants really
but don't you think I would have thought
that lawyers would be the one thing that
he does spend money on because it's like
we need to we need to be able to work
the system here and you guys no one's to
do that well he has not done so in the
in the Russian collusion investigation
he was using
in house government lawyers for most of
it he had one private lawyer I think he
was under compensated no he doesn't like
spending money annoyed would you say
that's ill-advised I would yes I think
you you know believe me if Robert mother
should trump up some bogus charge
against me because he can't find any
evidence of Russian collusion or
WikiLeaks collaboration or advanced
knowledge of John Podesta is for [ __ ] to
emails I'm certainly going to use a good
lawyer you can bet on that
yeah who do you think the Democrats are
gonna pull for a couple years from now
I'm praying for Joe Biden you wanted Joe
Biden the child molester is your nominee
that would make that would be phenomenal
I don't know if he's on the record as a
child and cannot keep his hands off
other people's children we're not
talking about five pictures 10 pictures
we're talking about hundreds of pictures
but it's not like creepy about that's
quick could that be though and I got
could that be because of the you know
you eat maybe he looks at things
differently because he had that tragedy
in his life or his kids were you know
didn't his daughter died in an accident
or something so maybe you look at
children differences appreciates the
children like oh yeah even though this
likes to touch other people's kids I
mean there's that option as well Rogers
gave kids hugs sure and he wasn't a
molester I don't think it was a TV
children's talk host it may be a
slightly different I see I says a
terrific picture on on Twitter today of
Joe with his hand over some little boy's
mouth there's something creepy about
this guy so you saw let's be clear he's
a lightweight
right he's got grandiose views of his
own stature but he'd been wrong about
every major issue he's run for president
three times and gotten it's gotten no
votes yeah I hope he runs do you think
Trump would handling Oh God
if Trump hires you look it's interesting
because Biden constantly refers to
physical violence against his opponents
when he ran for the Senate 20 years ago
in a high school debate debate being
held at a high school he threatened to
take his opponent out behind the gym and
thrash him
the guy outweighed Joe by 60 pounds Joe
would have gone down fast
he's scrawny he's a lightweight right
he's going nowhere so if Trump if it
comes out okay it's now 2020 whatever it
is Trump is running against Joe Biden
and Trump goes Roger I'm gonna hire you
to help me out with this campaign do you
go okay first we need to build this
thing that portrays Joe Biden as a child
molester
well would you
I'm a dad I'm a great believer in visual
imagery just put together a videotape of
him inappropriately touching children
but show where the parents have to slap
his hand away from their kids it's out
there you can find it but that's the
direction you would absolutely go find
him creepy I think he's creepy
yeah okay is it creepy with the child
just to mush their hair a little you
know look everything is relative but I
see then a lot when I'm in the street if
I don't know that y'all just mushed
their hair that's that'll get you
arrested hair mustn't I don't like that
encouragement it's no good hey do good
in school you without the approval of
their parents it's a bad idea but I look
at the parents I'm like and I just I
look at the kid I look at that brother
all right and I'll just mess his hair
but you wouldn't stick to the issues is
what I'm saying you'd more go with their
much agreement on issues right if if Joe
Biden wants to compare the economy under
eight years of Obama Biden with the
current economy I would welcome that
comparison I think Trump wants to run
against and he always gets it's wrong
it's folk acontece FAU Expo kahan I saw
a kind of doesn't it yeah yeah you know
he doesn't but I like she called her
liya Wafaa - that's not bad that's a
good one do you think that Elizabeth
Warren is a great threat to Trump if she
runs yeah boy I worry about that every
night not right you know under under
federal law we have massive programs for
Native Americans the Native American
community leads the country in in
illiteracy drug abuse alcoholism and so
on you have all these federal programs
plus as you know under a 1988 a piece of
legislation they're allowed to consult
conduct extremely lucrative casino
gambling in certain states you have to
be one-eighth Indian to participate
that's the law that's the federal
measure of whether or not you're a
Native American so she didn't even come
close
was she not one-eighth not even close oh
one like 1,000 which you know I mean if
we borrow tested you guys you you'd have
the same I mean most Americans do we all
came from somewhere right but he goaded
her into taking the test that alone show
he's the greatest troll of all time by
the way that's the second time he's done
that the first time it was the President
and it was Obama having to finally show
his birth
because Trump kept pestering him yeah
you get a lot of credit for doing stuff
like do you still chat with him a lot he
sends messages through third parties I
think his lawyers have suggested that
until we get through the Russian
collusion nonsense that's right probably
best not to talk to me directly which is
unfortunate because I could give him a
lot of good advice if you were to end up
in jail would you call him from jail to
give advice you know I don't answer
hypothetical questions okay that's smart
but if I end up in jail send in some
filet mignon we'll you know what's wrong
with manna for no mana for and I were
partners 30 years ago he has no idea
what I was doing after I left the
campaign and frankly I don't know what
he was doing when he was in the campaign
other than counting delegates and saving
down from ass at the convention hmm so
this idea that he has something to tell
is ludicrous also kind of this late in
the game you know if they don't have a
case against me for Russian collusion
they don't
WikiLeaks collaboration please give me a
break or John Podesta's incredibly
incriminating emails I don't know what
manna fork could possibly tell them that
would not be a fabrication and then it
would be provable I have no animus
towards him him towards me
no I'm concerned about it